I think the worst thing that happened to
me was the time one time we got there
police called on us ha ha ha and
explained why we got the police call
just we didn't do anything illegal we'd
play Mario Party really loud yeah those
are bad you know we caught we caught we
can't really complain about that okay so
basically we got a noise complaint so
the policeman came and he basically
asked Joey you know who who is he with
yeah and I remember you you saying like
oh there's you know one American one you
know British person and then there's was
me who I'm Thai so he mentioned that I'm
I'm with the time and as soon as he
mentioned that heels with a Thai friend
the police the police means like oh can
we'll see your Thai friend
can we see your third friends and my
eyes like I go up there and I start
getting grilled about why I'm here they
want to see my passport and everything
and they ask me my visa but you showed
them your British paws I don't know as
soon as I as soon I was like oh I have a
British passport though they were like
okay you're free to go I was like oh
what the
who was that I was so messed up like and
and the fact that they like only called
you yeah yeah up there even though there
was like a it was like the most multi
like cultural room probably the entire
apartment built i'ma say it now I wasn't
making the noise anything like that was
the first time I like ever experienced
that too and I'm just like yeah thought
a little bow no no no yeah I'm like you
do know like this is like not cool Yeah
right like to them it's just yeah